كان دونالد ترامب أول رئيس
أمريكي يتم انتخابه بدون أي خبرة سياسية أو
عسكرية وظفته
، وستكون انتخابات 2020 بمثابة
استفتاء على السنوات الأربع الأولى له في
المنصب ،
إنها انتخابات تعرف من يعرف ما
يحدث بشكل صحيح ، أعتقد أننا  ذاهب للفوز ،
أعتقد أننا سنفوز بالكثير من
ترامب أثار نبرة مثيرة للانقسام منذ
بداية حملته الرئاسية
عندما ترسل المكسيك لأفرادها أنهم لا
يرسلون أفضل
ما لديهم أنهم يجلبون المخدرات إنهم يجلبون
الجريمة
.  إعادة المغتصبين ، ترى شخصًا ما
يستعد لرمي طماطم
يطرد الفضلات منه ،
وأعدك بأنني سأدفع الرسوم القانونية التي
يطالب بها دونالد جي ترامب
بإغلاق تام وكامل
للمسلمين الذين يدخلون الولايات المتحدة
واستمر ذلك في الأبيض  منزل
حيث ركز على قاعدته الشعبوية من
الناخبين وجدول أعماله المحلي الأول
من هذا اليوم فصاعدًا ، ستكون
أمريكا فقط أولاً
اليسار الراديكالي يكرهون
تاريخنا يكرهون قيمنا ويكرهون
عشية  أي شيء
نمنحه كأميركيين أنت تعرف ما
أنا قومي ،
فاز ترامب بالكلية الانتخابية
بفوزه بولايات رئيسية مثل
بنسلفانيا ميشيغان وويسكونسن في عام
على الرغم من خسارة التصويت الشعبي الذي توصل إليه
تحقيق استمر لمدة عامين بقيادة
المستشار الخاص روبرت
مولر  أن روسيا تدخلت في
انتخابات عام 2016 بهدف مساعدة ترامب على
الفوز
، اتهم أعضاء حملته
بارتكاب جرائم ، لكن التحقيق
لم يجد
أي تنسيق بين الحملة الرابحة
وروسيا
إذا كانت لدينا ثقة في أن
الرئيس لم يرتكب جريمة بوضوح.
كنا نقول إن
ترامب قد أمضى جزءًا كبيرًا من
وقته في المنصب في التراجع عن العديد من
سياسات الرئيس أوباما
لإعادة التفاوض بشأن صفقات التجارة الخارجية
وتقليل اللوائح الحكومية
، كما قام أيضًا بتعيين
قاضيين من المحكمة العليا المحافظة وهما
نيل غورسوش وبريت كافانو أثناء
وجوده في منصبه.  مشروع
قانون يهدف إلى جعلنا أعمالًا أكثر
تنافسية على مستوى العالم
لدينا شركات  بالتدفق مرة أخرى إلى
بلدنا ، أعلن انسحاب الأمة
من اتفاقية باريس للمناخ ،
كما تعلمون ، يبدو الأمر لطيفًا للغاية ،
لكنه كان قاتلًا ، لقد كان قاتلاً
لبلدنا ، كما دعم شكلاً مصغرًا من
قانون الرعاية المعقولة التكلفة
ولكن الفاتورة سقطت  صوت واحد قصير عندما
صوت السناتور جون ماكين بـ "لا"
في عام 2019 ، يُزعم أن الرئيس ترامب
حجب المساعدة العسكرية
لأوكرانيا مقابل خدمة سياسية شخصية ،
تم اعتماد تحقيق في نجل جو بايدن ،
المادة الأولى تم تبنيها في
مجلس النواب الذي عزل
الرئيس ترامب بتهمة إساءة استخدام السلطة
والعرقلة.  من الكونغرس
لإقالة دونالد جون ترامب
، أجريت محاكمة عالية المخاطر في
مجلس الشيوخ لتحديد ما إذا كان
ينبغي عزل ترامب من منصبه.
كما أعلن الرئيس ترامب فوز
covet-19 قد وصلت الولايات المتحدة
ترامب منع غير الأمريكيين في الصين
من دخول البلاد
ولكن بشكل عام قللوا من أهمية الفيروس شديد
العدوى
حيث استمر في الانتشار ، سيختفي
هذا دون لقاح ،
ولن نراه مرة أخرى
بعد فترة من
الوقت قاده  لأزمة اقتصادية
وتودي بحياة الأمريكيين أكثر من الحرب العالمية
الأولى ، وفي ظل هذه الظروف
يسعى الرئيس ترامب إلى أربع
سنوات أخرى في منصبه
إذا فاز ، سيصبح أول
رئيس يتم عزله
في التاريخ الأمريكي يعاد انتخابه
لولاية ثانية.